the Great Depression left millions of able
and willing Americans bewildered and jobless
in 1933 the federal government came to the help
of local agencies which had fought a courageous
but losing fight against the growing need for
relief but the Dole was not enough good sound
men Hammond wanted to earn the help they got to
hold up their heads to keep themselves from going
rusty retail business needed their purchasing
power to stimulate trade and all over America
communities needed all sorts of improvements
and public services which had been cut off or
postponed during the lean years when local
revenues were pitifully low 35 is the key
agency in the federal work program to employ
able people from relief rows projects were
inaugurated and sponsored by local officials
who also subscribe local funds to buy materials
and supplement the federal money which went
largely in wages to the workers what does the
WPA program mean to the rest of the country
as a whole does this work pay America here
is a record of it to judge for yourself city
streets founded by ever-increasing traffic are
modernized resurfaced thousands of blocks which
mean huge savings in local tax money vital to
the communities which they serve are the thousands
of miles of highways constructed and improved by
the works program the need for first-class
highways grows constantly the automobile
and the motor truck become increasingly
important in both city and rural Commerce
in many regions great losses befallen farmers
and other rural residents during periods of bad
weather which made secondary roads impassable
the need for adequate farm-to-market roads
which would make the transportation of farm
produce independent of weather conditions has
been recognized in all parts of the country but
not until the beginning of the works program was
it possible to initiate a general plan for the
development of farm-to-market roads this plan
brings immediate improvement in local business
and property values wherever a secondary road is
completed at last the farmer finds it possible
to reach his market over well-constructed
weatherproof roads in all these construction
projects local labor is employed and wherever
possible the raw materials are obtained from
quarries in the immediate vicinity how big is
the WPA Road program in its first 18 months
of operation the mileage end-to-end would
have stretched five times around the earth in
many parts of the country our region's which
depend largely upon the tourists trade as a local
industry areas of great scenic beauty have been
made available to thousands of visitors through
the development of systems of roads in national
and state parks and at other centres of attraction
for tourists many of these vacation spots were
completely inaccessible before the assistant of
the works program made road construction possible
the welfare of the community served by
a new construction project is always
the first consideration and plans are
laid not only for the present but for
the more demanding future in the field of
public health many important and permanent
improvements have been undertaken the water
resources of thousands of cities and towns
have been expanded by the construction
of reservoirs and water supply system
ensuring an adequate supply of water for
the community's need for many years to come
a particularly interesting example of a
long felt need met by the works program
is this reservoir at Atlantic City although
this resort entertains millions of visitors
every year it never has had an adequate water
supply until this breadth of where I was built
another type of permanent construction is this
community stadium representative of a large
group of projects that provide facilities
for public gatherings all over America in
cooperation with other federal agencies
many important improvements have been made
under the works program at the Brooklyn Navy
Yard and other centers of government activity
as an aide to traffic hundreds of new
bridges have been completed designed
to withstand high waters and the founding
of heavy loads thousands of other bridges
have been repaired and made safe many cities
have been freed from the peril of disease
by the provision of modern scientific correct
sewage systems which often replace antiquated
systems entirely inadequate for the needs of
the community developments such as these are
always undertaken with the cooperation of the
public health agencies serving each locality
and the projects are carried out under the
supervision of competent sanitary engineers
the rapid growth of air traffic outdistanced
airport facilities so hundreds of cities seize
the opportunity offered by the WPA to build
or improve modern airports one of the busiest
of all airports is at Newark this field is
the eastern terminus of all of the great
transcontinental airlines and hundreds of
transport ships land and take off from its
runways every day at Newark has at a great many
other cities the works program has provided jobs
for thousands of workers in the improvement
of existing facilities and a new construction
at Cleveland great industrial Center emergency
workers built an immense landing mat the largest
single piece of paving in the world at Detroit
both construction and improvements were completed
second largest of American cities and first in
ranked in transportation is Chicago where an
extensive program of airport improvements
have given the city adequate air terminal
facilities Philadelphia is third among our
cities in population yet this Pennsylvania
metropolis has never had its own airport
passengers bound for Philadelphia by air
have been forced to land in another city in fact
in another state not until the great works program
became a reality was it possible to begin the
construction of this air terminal on the site
of the famous Hog Island shipyards the increase
in air transportation has also made necessary
the development of hundreds of emergency landing
fields along the regular flying routes frequently
the need for these fields is greatest where
the work of preparation is most difficult
but safety and passenger transport requires
the clearing of fields at frequent intervals
in the larger cities where the concentration of
population is greatest slum clearance project
have been undertaken in some areas new modern
housing developments will be erected providing
better living conditions for workers in the
low-income groups in other locations the
land cleared will be used for public parks
and playgrounds in all parts of the country
the letters WPA are a symbol of progress and
improvement on buildings under construction they
mean the replacement of inadequate public
facilities by new well-planned structures
on buildings under repair they mean the
preservation of existing structures for
greater utility many thousands of such
jobs as these dot the map of the United
States giving work and hope to people who
can't find jobs impetus to retail trade and
heavy industry and permanent improvements to
a host of communities for the years to come
not only was it necessary to find employment
for workers accustomed to manual labor but also
there was need to employ others whose training
and experience fitted them for professional
and other skills work for these so-called
white-collar workers each community had to
plan jobs which would utilize and preserve
their skill and training and above all the
work must be useful a real contribution to the
welfare of the community in planning traffic
control for congested cities jobs have been
found which require varying degrees of skill
in the study of traffic problems the first step
is to determine the number of vehicles passing
a given point then experts are employed to
lay out new routes and regulations which
will ensure greater safety for both motorists
and pedestrians manpower for hundreds of such
surveys is provided by the works program tests
have been devised to determine the ability and
fitness of drivers so that the element of human
failure may be eliminated in cooperation with the
police departments of several cities automobile
inspection stations have been established in an
effort to reduce the number of unsafe vehicles on
the road under the supervision of expert mechanics
every safety device is carefully checked for
perfect operation the laws of many states and
cities require a regular inspection of this
nature and the possession of an up-to-date
inspection label is necessary before the car owner
may use his automobile on the streets and highways
another example of useful employment is found in
the sewing rooms operated by the works program in
practically every city in the country expert
craftsmanship is encouraged in design groups
associated with the sewing projects women who are
the principle support of their families are paid
for their work and the millions of garments
and miscellaneous articles they produce are
distributed free to families on relief or detect
supported institutions or some of the women who
work in these sewing rooms the training and
practical experience they receive will not
only make them better housewives but it may also
open up avenues to a permanent source of income
many other types of employment are provided for
women in a number of weaving projects instruction
is given in an interesting and useful craft
part-time employment is provided in many kitchens
where clean wholesome school lunches are prepared
for undernourished children of needy families in
libraries and schools skilled workers are employed
in repairing and rebounding millions of books
in many places where books were hard to find
over 2,000 traveling libraries now supply the
demand for knowledge and entertainment
in public nursing projects are employed
graduate and registered nurses who have been
removed from the relief role some of the nurses
visit homes often in isolated localities
bringing instruction to needy and working
mothers in the care and feeding of children
special attention is given to maternity care
and general health supervision where no other
medical assistance of this nature is available
the nursing projects bring health and happiness
where formerly death and misery were all too
common their visits run into the Midland new
interests have vanquished the darkness of
despair in the lives of thousands of cyclists
men and women as a result of several projects
in which books and maps have been translated
into Braille the written language of the blind
the proofreading of these works is done by
sightless experts in some cities instruction is
given in the reading of Braille maps the tragedy
of blindness has been the lot of thousands of our
people in regions where trachoma ad red eye
disease is prevalent many of its victims are
prevented by poverty isolation or infirmity from
receiving medical attention to these people come
visiting nurses to examine suspected cases and
provision has been made for transportation to
free clinics with this assistance medical science
has found it possible to control a disease which
is a menace to young and old alike in many
cases affecting every member of a large family
needless to say the staff necessary
to maintain this important service
is recruited from the trained workers of
the region's concerned and again useful
employment is combined with an enterprise of
great and immediate value to the community
everyone is familiar with the fine work being done
by the famous Warm Springs foundation and the cure
of children crippled by infantile paralysis to
thousands who would otherwise be hopeless crippled
for the rest of their lives had been given the
chance to overcome their handicaps much of the
success of the treatment given at Warm Springs
and elsewhere depends upon the existence of
therapeutic pools in which patients may gradually
recover the use of their muscles through exercise
made easier by the support of warm water in many
parts of the country WPA labor has constructed
pools such as these and trained WPA workers make
up the steps which assist in the medical treatment
this therapeutic tool is in the James Whitcomb
Riley Memorial Hospital in Indiana made doubly
interesting by Riley's immortal poem about the
little crippled boy with curvature of the spine
in hundreds of cities the works program
safeguards the health of many thousands of
normal children of preschool age in nursery
schools the children of needy and working
mothers are provided with the best of care and
medical supervision projects which are part of
a broad educational program in which the WPA has
helped millions of children and adults supervise
play activities and preschool training under
competent instructors removed from the relief
roles are part of the schedule at each of
these nursery schools meals are provided for
the youngsters and plenty of health building
milk and orange juice is consumed during the
mid-morning and mid-afternoon luncheons the food
is prepared under the supervision of dietitians
and at all times a careful check of the health
and development of the children is maintained
in these nursery schools the youngsters acquire
habits which will guard their health later in
life here is a work which lays the foundation
for a new generation of good citizens another
part of the works program enters the field of
adult education and this subject embraces a
number of widely varied projects some of the most
interesting of the WPA projects in adult education
are the classes in which hundreds of thousands
of foreign-born people learn the language and
customs of their adopted country vocational
training projects are another branch of the
adult education program many classes have been
established in which instruction is given to men
and women who will find very practical uses
for their newly acquired knowledge in their
daily lives every effort is made to adapt the
instruction to the need and native ability of
the student women are instructed in the arts
and crafts for which they are best fitted
as exemplified in the millinery classes in the
same general category we find classes for men in
which the students are initiated into the art of
tailoring through the training they received here
they will be unable to take up a profitable trade
which will assure them of work and independence
a project which combines rehabilitation and
education is found in the many household training
classes operated by the WPA here future housewives
are instructed in home making and inexperienced
girls from relief families are given training
which will make them self-supporting as the
girls master each branch of household art their
progress is indicated on a chart upon graduation
the girls are placed through an employment
service conducted by the works program to the
young people of the nation eager in their quest
of knowledge the works program in cooperation
with the National Youth administration offers
part-time employment to enable them to continue
their education the type of employment offered is
determined by the needs of the community in which
the young people live in fruit growing districts
canning units have been set up in which girls can
and preserve fruit for local householders part of
the product is distributed to families on relief
an interesting project in New England is that in
which boys many of them from seafaring families
are engaged in the catching and breeding of
fish and the restocking of fishing grounds
as they cast their nets into the sea the action
symbolises their search for education security
the simple riches of life and toward this
objective the normal heritage of every young
American the works program offers them a
helping hand incitive fingers of artists
are poorly suited to manual labor and in
finding suitable work for musicians and
other artists the WPA has contributed greatly
to the culture of America a typical project is
this Negro choir singing the spirituals
that are the real folk music of America
painters to contribute their bit to
making the works program a real and
permanent accomplishment these
reproductions of the American
scene of today will make this one of the
most fertile periods of our countries our
some of this work is done on canvas but much of it
is created on the walls of our schools libraries
and other public buildings in the form of mural
paintings of particular interest is the great
mural in the mess hall of the Military Academy
at West Point depicting great warriors of history
an art long-dormant in the United States
is the creation of stained-glass windows
one project devoted to this art has made
a window for the Military Academy at West
Point depicting scenes from the life of Washington
commemorative tablets like this are among the
contributions of sculptors to the works program
and they also create works of art for our parks
and public buildings many American museums have
long been in need of highly skilled experts
to restore valuable historical materials such
as this Persian ceiling which is forming
under the deft fingers of a WPA artist
in the Philadelphia Museum in many other
museums fossils and animal skeletons are
being prepared and mounted for study one
of the outstanding cultural achievements
of the works program is the federal theater
for many years vast sections of our country
have not seen a flesh-and-blood theatrical
performers to these areas the WPA has brought
a new type of entertain and at the same time
enrich the art of the theater in metropolitan
centers federal theater presentations are of
many types puppet shows such as this for the
children open-air variety shows playing in
parks minstrels musical comedies and others
here are excerpts from three of
the most popular federal theater
presentation starting with Gilbert
and Sullivan's operetta pinafore
and now we see the federal theater production
of Sinclair Lewis drama it can't happen here on
the green I want to burn up all this it's the
birth of literature what a smaii stuff that's
proper public now and here's an objection well you
won't find any subversive books here now how about
this now this fella Charles Dickens wasn't leader
communist and the old Negro production of Macbeth
vampy he would first cries hold enough
inevitably comes disaster as it has through
all the ages of history so today blood fire
and famine relentlessly persecute the human
race in this land of ours so bountifully
supplied by nature with fertile lands and
rich forests disaster has taken a terrible
toll raging floods have swept the green
valleys imprisoning great cities in the
grasp of icy waters leaving destruction
and the threat of disease in their wake
but in the moment of greatest need the
shaft troops of disaster go into action
with the courage and perseverance which
armed our forefathers against despair
the shock troops of disaster the great army
of WPA workers diverted from their work of
construction and improvement to meet a pressing
emergency have proven their merit through many
tragic hours which have carried a far-flung
areas of the nation working hand-in-hand with
other agencies of relief the men and women of
the WPA take up the work of rescue evacuation
and relief but the first thought for the
saving of imperiled lives and the protection
of threatened areas from advancing waters
the orderly program goes swiftly forward
food is distributed to flood victims
from outdoor kitchens and car loads of
warm clothes and bedding are rushed - shivering
refugees from WPA sewing rooms in many states
in emergency hospitals thousands
of lives are saved by Red Cross
and volunteer nurses and doctors
assisted by trained WPA workers
for hundreds of miles along the flood
area the WPA supplies the shock troops
that hold the river within man-made walls
levee workers transport material by hand
by truck by boat working day and night
they fill countless thousands of sandbags
raising the levees above the record press
often working under the skilled direction
of Army engineers relief workers
fight the flood at every point
the people of the flood area will not
soon forget the courage of these heroic
workers for administrator Harry
Hopkins heard their praise along
the full route of his inspection trip
as head of the President's Committee
as the waters subside after the work of rescue
is completed comes a new battle against the
threat of disease the wreckage and debris left
by the flood must be quickly removed proper
conditions of Sanitation must be reestablished to
prevent the epidemics which were once certain to
take an additional toll of life and so from
the first moment of danger to the day when
life again takes up it even blow the works
program offers aid to those who need it most
the roaring waters that bring disaster to
fertile valleys have a terrible rival in
the drought which has afflicted thousands
of square miles of our western plains ruin
and famine come in the wake of the hot dry winds
which tear the rich soil from the grass roots here
again the shock troops of disaster marshal
their forces against devastation dust once
the valuable topsoil of the farm country is now
carried in whirling clouds choking and blinding
people and livestock rolling on higher wider
and blacker until the land itself upon which
everything else depends the land it took nature
100 years for the inch to build up is blowing away
in this emergency to the shock
troops of disaster marshal their
forces against devastation with the aid of
WPA workers food housing and medical care
are provided for those who have been driven
from their home stairs by the threat of panic
there is great immediate danger from inflammation
of eyes throats and lungs tortured by dust expert
clinical care for children and adults is provided
to minimize the danger to life and health
in addition to their vital work of providing
the necessities of life for Refugees the WPA
has found work for thousands of farmers who have
been deprived of a livelihood by the drought these
men are working on projects important to the
afflicted area such as roads entirely to them
this work provides a means of carrying on in
the face of the hardships inflicted by nature
drought is a grave national problem correcting at
a mammoth undertaking as a step in this direction
relief workers are engaged in the construction
of many dams to conserve due to rainfall
construction work on water conservation project
requires an immense number of skilled and
unskilled workers providing immediate employment
for hundreds of those who would otherwise be on
relief those who suffered because of the drought
are now employed on projects designed for their
own future benefit thus the Works program answers
the need of both the individual and the community
with drought comes the added peril of fire
an ever-present danger to lives and property
in forests covered regions fire is a constant
menace to one of the nation's greatest assets
the great timber lands which are so important
to industry under the very life of our soil
when the hot Sun through long rain this
leaks has baked leaves and wood to the
dryness of tinder it requires only the spark of a
cigarette or a flash of lightning to bring about
devastation and grow it manpower is needed
to fight the plains to prevent the spread of
fiery destruction and again the shock troops of
disaster rally to the challenge dropping their
normal work of construction and improvement to
respond to the emergency needs of the nation
parks playgrounds and other recreation areas
play an increasingly important part in the
lives of our people the construction improvement
and maintenance of thousands of such centers
under the works program provides millions of
people with healthful pleasant surroundings
for relaxation and play in regions of congested
population the WPA has cooperated with national
and state park agencies in the improvement of
recreational areas easily accessible to those
who live in large cities countless thousands
of men women and children each year make use
of the new facilities for play and relaxation
in the cities themselves playgrounds have been
opened in every conceivable location employment
has been provided for thousands of skilled and
unskilled workers engaged in the preparation and
equipment of parts and playgrounds where children
who formerly were forced to play in the streets
may find safe recreation many of these playgrounds
are staffed by trained instructors drawn from
the relief roads during the oppressive heat of
summer swimming pools are a haven of refuge for
young and old alike hundreds of such pools with
well-equipped bath houses have been constructed
by WPA lay the trained supervisors and instructors
provided for these recreation centers have been
removed from relief roles a new idea in bringing
happiness to underprivileged children is the toy
lending library established as an experiment in
an Eastern City a large supply of toys is kept on
hand and the youngsters are allowed to borrow one
at a time hundreds of young children find their
dreams brought to life in this novel enterprise
the conservation of human resources is one of the
great objectives toward which the works program
has directed its efforts the boys and girls
of today are the citizens of tomorrow and it
is our responsibility to assist them in becoming
good citizens underprivileged children and those
formerly cared for in various institutions have
been removed from unhealthy environments and
given a chance to spend at least part of the
year in the wholesome atmosphere of camp life
in these fine camps an abundance of good
food is provided and medical attention
and general supervision are insured
by staffs of trained WPA employees
national monuments and regions of historic
importance such as Fort Niagara attract
thousands of visitors from all parts of the
country and the pleasure which these visitors
derive is enhanced by the improvements and
maintenance provided by the works program
many frontier forts built during and before
the Revolution have been restored to their
original condition to commemorate
the valour of the nation's pioneers
parts of several Midwest states provided the
background for Abraham Lincoln's early light
the WPA has constructed or restored several
historic friends to Lincoln's boiler here
are cabins representing the store in which he
worked his early home the law office from which
he borrowed books and other reminders
of the presence of this great American
in this picture we have seen a few of the
120,000 projects that are embraced by the
works program each of these projects has been
planned to meet a real need in the community
which it serves to take care of the unemployed
as well as to confer real and lasting benefits
on the people of the United States is the object
of the WPA under this program work pays America